je te demande si ce que dit à jojo se
retrouve sur ce rejet en civil à tort
alors oui ce jeu a été fait par environ
tous les youtube heures gaming qu'il
soit 1 mais bon j'avais envie de faire
une petite vidéo de tuer étant donné
qu'il est quand même sacrément phone
house party
nous sommes dans l'espace au revoir au
nord en tout de suite bis bis a tous
fait l'amour il ya des bébés macaques
llc mois au père aimant malak
tranquillement on s'appelle chérie je
fais juste un petit on laisse pas après
ces quelques blagues plutôt nul squeeze
décida de prendre le pouls d'une vidéo
normal alors on doit lui péter les côtes
eh ben on va se faire une joie de lui
péter les cotes sauver son nom revient
en chine
je lui ai arraché un bout de sourcils
[ __ ] voilà parfait c'est bon ça
suffira allez allez on si ses côtés plus
vite donc il ya juste un million de
copeaux de dos
dégueulasse donc quel genre de personne
à un réveil comme ça dans sa peau sa
capsule dans l'espace personne
absolument personne s as tu veux que je
refasse les dons tiens ça va là non plus
comme ça oui voilà à aller moi ton
oreille puisque j'ai coupé celle de ma
femme hier soir non je me suis piquée
oui j'étais sous l'effet d'une drogue
assez dur appelé drogue
ça fait penser que ces scènes pour ce à
quoi un xylophone en version os c'est
pareil hervé ça le fait on m'appelle ce
watchers autrement dit le boucher en
français c'est moi c'est français mais
il lui reste deux [ __ ] de côte qui va
lui casser ou tuvalu caresser aller
olalala au lac est passé haut la la
halde tu vas le coupé ixo ce samedi
qu'elle fait une piqûre il va mourir tu
allais mois la peau coeur non c'est un
peu d'outils je n'ai pas eu peur j'ai
dit donnez moi la paix coeur on te
retire un poumon pour que ton décès soit
mémorable et les bords avec un seul
poumon
ce qui ne change absolument rien si je
vais dans une tombe tu deviens très vite
squelette est un mec je peux pas le
faire pour sauver ta peau je te propose
si j'arrive à la à l'attraper [ __ ] ou
télé ou cas les tours de magie tu l'as
pas vu au regardez comme c'est beau elle
a eu peur que dans la vie tels se casse
on saute fois la vidéo est ce que un
médecin a déjà fait une opération dans
l'espace si oui je lui donne une
médaille mais n'importe quelle médaille
une médaille en chocolat
puis ces beaux tous ces petits morceaux
d'os qui vole comme ça dans l'air ah
c'est tellement beau on dirait pas
l'ailé sociale culturelle du père des
caraïbes ont été importés mois de
l'argent et je me fasse refaire les
tentacules là il va falloir que tu es
les démarcheurs du coeur et ça va être
voilà on peut les retirer à temps c'est
plus ou en coton tige ya pas un petit un
petit scalpel je dois faire ça avec mes
dents boudent toujours je te dérange un
peu quand même
ah [ __ ] de bois tu dégages il est au
coeur de tout à l'heure c'est ça non
c'est pas ça en haut un cadeau du ciel
et maintenant on fait comment pour lui
mettre dedans
piquionne la pesanteur non mais tu pas
que non juifs aux hauts diplômes
university of barna jdir nickel burke
ah là là pardon excusez moi où est mon
ami mon téléphone
attention musique épique tout ça pour
atteindre indicateurs
yb a filé au trône
est-ce qu'on peut pas coupe est une
pilule
non non à un accord donc je lui abîme
juste visage l'avait demandé une
chirurgie esthétique
excuse moi c'est et est avec toi tu te
réveilles pas je t'éclate se moqua sur
ta gueule alors maintenant il faut faire
ça hop ni qu'elle fait allez hop
oh comme c'est beau aussi illuminé on
voit même ma mère mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle est nue dans mon jardin avant
les tripes le dégager voila voila
parfait voilà tout s'envole
hop hop dégage et maintenant les jeunes
hommes en tout cas prendre ce gros
machin là tu mettais musique classique
tu avais une scène à la fois très
mignonne et à la fois extrêmement
violente
allez allez olla aulas on arrache up
ces bourses dégage non non jamais les
partis loin ils vont m'entendre
la catastrophe dans merde on arrête qui
s'échappe dans la cellule 2 je reviens
dans [ __ ] on voit juste ou des trucs
sauf lors à quoi leur en laye les
primaires il est noir est humain est
nôtre se goure à s'est échappé voilà il
fait du ping pong dans la cabine
super je crois que le deuxième il est
laid sorti de la cabine
il est actuellement dans un nuage la
barre voilà alors on a on n'a pas un
rond mais on a un réveil un alors on va
tenter de foot ce [ __ ] non ok ok on
peut pas et on s'est fait baiser il nous
a échappé
aux pierres oh oui oh oui oui non oui oh
non c'est mauvais non mais c'est pas
possible
oh oui oui oh oui oh oui
dégage à l'est oui a laissé comme des
pommes dauphines en plus dégueulasse
oyonnax la non feinte te faire [ __ ]
si t'es pas content je te mets se doit
dans ton nez et peut-être aussi en effet
ce vos améliorations technologiques les
moustiques en développe elle super
pouvoirs de disparaître
et maintenant jours l'escrimeur
du coup anne